ah okay things
ah kind of close with this sometimes
don't I all right yeah every time I try
and fix this setup I hate it yeah all
right oh there's that sorry I'm sure
this is what everyone wanted to be
looking at as I try and sort this stupid
thing now enjoy a close-up view of my
frustration face as I try and get this
to behave the way ah I hiked with it
that's that's what we're going with
so haha how's everybody doing shift
myself trying Center oh man haha this is
it's kind of been one of those days a
little bit I'm gonna shut the door sorry
the degree to which I was not as prepped
as I had intended to be is frankly
embarrassing alright Oh huh
The Sixth Doctor is the best okay we're
getting right into it now the thing is
though that's actually not nearly as
controversial a stance as it once was
thanks to Big Finish uh hot time in
Jacksonville 2:00 a.m. on my end I'm
absolutely shattered but I thought I
might as well happen to wish everyone a
lovely evening PS that includes you boss
Thank You Joel thank you for stopping in
now get some sleep man
come on uh what are your pronouns
everybody drink um I don't care
hello monsters is a classic yes
delicious water I do wonder if the
prompting on this is just gonna end up
getting me a whole bunch of people
saying stuff just to bait me
not that I'm Nessa that cuz that's
that's just a rabbit hole but you know
you have to wonder sometimes and
actually this is the I explaining why I
decided to have like an unpopular
opinions themed thing is difficult to to
like explain this is actually toned down
from like my initial thought I I
initially thought I'd have it be like
the debate me livestream like and really
just poke the bear and I was in an
argumentative
dude yesterday so I softened it into
this so again I can't really give you a
reason the twin dilemma is great oh my
goodness I just got done with the tennis
dog hold on
ah ah hold on something went past me I
just got done with a 10th doctor with
the 11th do you have any recommended
episodes well start with this first one
start with the 11th hour it's actually
really good but top recommendations
after that I guess Amy's choice the girl
who waited a lot of people don't like
asylum of the Daleks
I do actually quite a bit doctor's wife
that'd be a good one like I hate to dunk
on Clara but there aren't a lot of great
eleventh Doctor stories with her so
stick to Amy Rory
that's why can't I get this thing to
quite behave on me stranger things to
Episode seven was great see the thing is
I actually believe that that is one of
my own unpopular opinions but a big part
of that has to do with the fact that I
did not particularly like most of the
rest of strange things too so episode
seven was like a breath of fresh air for
me did you see the interview with Sean
Pertwee about his dad anniversary I did
I did see that Kathleen that was really
sweet
I mean if folks don't know sunday was
jon pertwee the third doctor's 100th
birthday or you know would have been if
he hadn't passed on I mean it still is
he's just not here to celebrate it and
the official Doctor Who channel put up
an interview with Sean Pertwee John's
son who is also an actor he was Alfred
and Gotham and he's quite good talking
about you know growing up in that house
and with Doctor Who and it was nice it
was it was really sweet
Batman and Robin is so bad as good no no
Batman or Robin is so bad it's bad I
tried going back and watching it through
that lens I still still can't still
cannot you want to go about FMA I don't
know what that means
I don't like council of geeky hos
totally not baby you mwah ha ha you know
I want to give you the benefit of the
doubt but there's something about mwah
ha ha specifically I just mm-hmm series
9 is the second best series for me I
adore it I actually think series that I
earn is over hated it has the episode
that I hate more than anything else and
it which is hell-bent but the series
overall actually it's better than most
people would give it credit for can you
say comic God is the man and now that's
gonna get pulled for something and used
in isolation
I'm sure the eleventh Doctor's run is
overrated well
I'll get to judge that for myself when I
ate when I catch up to it and do a
proper re-watch I actually like some of
the Disney remakes get out not flying
I'm glad you like I actually oh oh I
think the fact that I have managed to
not see any of these like the only one
I've seen is Maleficent and I don't even
consider that as counting cuz it's such
a vastly different take I've not had to
see any of these I'm pretty sure I'm
gonna have to take my kids to see The
Lion King which is by far the most
pointless I feel I can be made to pay
for the fact that I got away with it
up to this point 2 a.m. in Dublin whoo
but I feel like as council of geeks most
unpopular opinion is saying you prefer
Sim at the end of time to simin the
sound of drums he's not as wacky in end
of time which is good cuz the wacky
didn't work for me
I don't know council of geeks is even
better than Stu bagful he's a close I
can throw that one I will disagree with
but you know that's that's me make you
vain attempt to be humble Jeffery
beavers is the best master well he's
he's not bad if you'd said Peter Pratt
we'd have some words even if I add sworn
off the remakes I would watch The Little
Mermaid and rave just to piss off the
not my Ariel folks okay Oh God look um
if for folks who don't follow me on
Twitter I'm just gonna put that I'm just
gonna throw this out there cuz I
actually put this up as a tweet I don't
know about an hour ago
um how much you want to bet that all the
people going how dare you racially
recast Ariel um you can't possibly
justify this are the exact same people
who were going why are you why are
people complaining about Scarlett
Johansson being cast as a trans man
she's the best for the part shut up you
know just saying ah
rdt made the Timelords too much like
time Wizards give us more tech about
litigious requests more techno babble
just reverse the polarity of the neutron
stream and call it a day man
okay I've also got some from the from
the discord which is patron exclusive so
oh here's an interesting one Tony Stark
is the worst character in the MCU he's
too egotistical self serving himself
important even when he's seemingly
playing the hero it's still all about
him I see you sokovia accords hmm so
that's actually kind of interesting
because depending on what you want out
of a hero that might be true I would
argue is quite possible that Tony is the
worst hero in the MCU that's actually
distinctly possible you can make a good
case for that worst character I don't
think so because I think this makes him
a very dynamic and interesting character
particularly the way he effects the
world and the other characters around
him but if you want to make an argument
for worst hero you might have a case
there additionally this is from the same
commenter Maria Rambo is a better
representation of a strong powerful
character in the Captain Marvel movie
then carol danvers herself and that also
got a shout out from another person so
like i'd have to think on that more i
really shouldn't see the movie again but
alright cool um i feel oh geez i've got
more people in this than I usually have
I am gonna have such a hard time keeping
up with the chat warn you folks right
now so apologies in advance for the fact
that I am gonna miss so many questions
all Doctor Who episodes should be nude
like the actor should be nude or should
be viewed nude have a nude view overdue
Doctor Who nude review oh dear
Loki is overrated well seal is actually
holds that same opinion so I've heard
that one before uh I tried to post this
last week but my internet broke Iain M
banks was only 34 when he wrote the
player of games he died young because of
cancer oh I didn't realize he was that
young I'd watch a nude review oh dear
hey oh boy I might be in trouble now
nude review with the OOD oh boy
how uh how rhymey can we get with this
let's string it along Captain Marvel is
an unbearably boring protagonist in the
MCU I'm not sure how much of a unpopular
opinion that is outlet I don't think the
majority people think that but it's an
opinion I've heard a fair bit at the
same time a Monsters Inc was the worst
Pixar movie really Cars two brave yeah
how crap on brave
I'm not know how much of a unpopular
opinion that is but I feel like it's
more unpopular than it should be because
like I did I could go into my whole
Pixar thing again just the fact that I
think Pixar as a company and their
overall output is overrated
it just is I'm not saying they haven't
made good movies am i saying they
haven't made great movies they have but
they don't have the batting average most
people give him credit for and
fundamentally I like the approach of
other studios over there approach
specifically Disney and I've laid that
out more specifically in a live stream
before I can do it again but like I feel
like I'm repeating
I'm not excited for the Little Mermaid
remake I'm fine with Halle Baily playing
the character there are people saying
that thinking that is racist the whole
idea of bringing race into a
mythological creature it's a mermaid it
already doesn't exist so like I I get I
get in so I get the gut reaction of
that's not how I remember it like I
don't want these movies to happen anyway
so like I don't care if it's like I
remember it or not but if you actually
joined these roommates I get the gut
reaction of that's not what I remember
that's not what I loved as a kid and I
get wanting that and you're not getting
it but like to actually say the words
she can't be black I'm like it's a
mermaid she could be purple heck
Ursula's purple why not
it's it's very strange well in like so
many things I get the initial gut
reaction of like oh but like do people
not stop and like think for two seconds
before they then open them their mouths
and then even after they said it they
don't go oh god what'd I just say they
like keep doubling down it's so weird so
weird to me
I don't know when as a culture we became
adverse to ever admitting that like we
said or did something stupid like it's
become the big thing to never apologize
I don't know why it's very dumb
if wingy media and some bankfull or not
your top five who tubers then you're
just playing wrong yeah yeah I can go
with that
Idris Elba as Triton would be perfect um
doesn't mean he'll have a shirt off the
whole time cuz I could go with that I
didn't like rogue one I feel like that's
an increasingly popular opinion I feel
like actually most of the Star Wars
movies aside from last year which was
immediately divisive but I think like we
force awakens and rogue one the initial
reaction was pretty positive and it's
been turning in the time since and I
don't know how much of that is because
of the device is a fitness that came
from from last Jedi but I just I feel in
general like way few people are prepared
to go to bat for it than when it first
came out
male damsel in distress is there a male
specific term for damsel know what I'm
saying we can't call guys damsels we can
I'm down for it
just saying if there's a movie I
ironically like it's Graham I got one
know her hi ho hey D here it's dumb but
I wouldn't say it's incompetent okay I'm
gonna ask because I don't know cuz I've
never seen it but like is this like the
animated thing or was like there ever a
live-action version of that I'm afraid
to ask
I like the Star Wars prequels also not
as unpopular an opinion as you might
think because I think a lot of people
who are younger than my generation um
like who were yo who were kid like
proper kids I was 17 when Episode one
came out so like people who were like a
decade younger than me have much more
nostalgic feelings for the prequels cuz
they were younger when they saw it I
like the new MJ and I don't mind her
being non-white but couldn't they have
found a reason to give her red hair even
if it's just died I suppose they could I
don't feel it's necessary but I mean
they could Family Guy has devolved into
a mean-spirited show um yeah I stopped
watching family guy a few years ago
which was a shame cuz while it it
sometimes pushed my buttons I it really
started turning me off a few years ago
60,000 subs by the end of the year he
had that's not happening my my goal is
forty I would like to have 40,000 subs
by the end of the year
see that's that's not happen like
realistically I don't think so I mean
like if it did that would be amazing but
like my subscription numbers would need
a serious shot in the arm versus the
pace that they're currently going so
let's see going back to the discord ooh
hmm
The Beatles while they do have a few
good songs are highly overrated I'm not
gonna name names for the ones put up in
the discord cuz I don't want people to
get piled on um
ooh that is a controversial one that I
actually kind of agree with now don't
get me wrong I like the Beatles I love
the beat I grew up on the Beatles
Beatles are great I don't think they're
the end-all be-all and if you sit me
down and say hey pick a 60s 70s rock
band to just listen to and have fun
Beatles is not gonna be my top choice
Beatles might not even make my top 5
before I would pop on the Beatles I
would listen to the stones I would
listen to Fleetwood Mac I would listen
to Queen I would listen to David Bowie I
would listen to Led Zeppelin that's not
saying I don't like the Beatles I'm just
saying they're a little bit they're one
of those bands that I can appreciate a
little bit more than I enjoy if that
makes sense
you don't think the Beatles are gods
Beatles have at least three good signs
I'd say they have more than that
do you like the doors I don't know what
ton of the doors stuff I only know a
couple so I'm not sure I'm in a position
to actually talk on that Kurt Cobain is
not the be-all end-all of grunge strong
stance and if I knew more about grunge I
can probably say but the indie since I
get probably true looks like you've got
some support on that - Teresa I don't
like the Beatles oh it's spreading have
you seen stranger things three I am I've
seen the first five episodes of stranger
things three
I saw I've got three more to go
hopefully I'm gonna try and be done by
at this point I suppose Thursday gotta
try and be done it's it's definitely
better than the second season it's not I
don't think it's as good as the first
season I'm not sure it can be because I
mean the first season just had a
surprise factor that can't fully be
replicated but it's definitely working
better for me than season two was excuse
me huh
well brie Larson said some stupid things
I think people took it too far
honestly I didn't even like huh let me
put it this way I am NOT gonna take a
stance on whether or not anything brie
Larson has or hasn't said is stupid the
reason I'm not is cuz the last time I
chose to dig into that when people kept
claiming oh I don't like her cuz of what
she said it was about Kathleen Kennedy
and when I dug into that and saw the
things that she actually had said and
the way they got twisted it just made me
deeply deeply deeply depressed and again
that's not me preemptively assuming brie
Larson never said anything that isn't
worthy of criticism but it just means I
have zero doubt that even to find that
I'm gonna have to sort through some
things that were badly twist
by people who had other reasons to
smearer and I just don't wanna just I
just don't anymore stranger things
season 2 is the best season Oh Sasha put
him on Oh frankly I think all right I
forgive me I'll leave that comment up in
the up in the chat there Casteel but I'm
not gonna quote it so you will have to
forgive me for that Michael Buble is
overrated I do kind of like Michael
Buble is he a highly-rated though I feel
like he's he's like he's he's music for
your mom and I say that as someone who
actually likes him the walking dead is
boring yes it is
I did one season and I have like vaguely
fall what's gone since then it is either
boring or cruel it seems to have only
those two modes there's why I don't
watch it galavant is underrated oh my
god yes galavant is so good it's on
Netflix both seasons are on Netflix
they're short seasons you can binge
through the whole thing in a weekend why
is it not gaining the cult following it
deserves it's so good the music is good
it's funny the characters are great the
first season is pretty good the second
season is great ah ha wait Viking days
of all there was a legend oh no not
gonna sing it cuz I'll get a copyright
claim on me
ah ok I can come down should I go I
don't wanna
I like Jackson's Hobbit trilogy you lied
yes but I still enjoy it well I'm glad
you at least admit flawed but ooh that's
a personal pain point for me that that
one
I'd sing along I'm sure you would
pirates least we got a couple of bars of
you singing
that's all you again cuz if I if I tried
to go beyond that I probably wouldn't
have been able to stay on key so it's
probably in everybody's interest the
sarong and conundrum isn't bad
no but it's bland I would still say it's
bad but it's like it's not it's not
aggressively bad it doesn't make me
angry the way something like a rack is
in the UK makes me angry all right jump
back to the discord my unpopular opinion
would just be superhero movies in
general because of the whole superhero
angle it's hard for them to really
subvert expectations because you just
expect superhero will super hero out of
it nearly all the time the danger is
quite clearly going to be resolved
anywho due to that so the suspense is
quite and quite often they also come up
with some really tiny details that end
up going in favor of the heroes and a
final bit to go ah got you audience for
that reason I find it hard to really
enjoy superhero movies find them too
predictable into force because superhero
angle forces them to come up with some
really odd get out cause at the end
that's actually kind of an interesting
point because like it's it's kind of an
inherent thing in general with most
movies that you tend to assume the
hero's gonna survive but in the wit and
the age of franchises that is even more
of a foregone conclusion that it used to
be so I think a lot of us you know I
love superhero movies but I do get your
point that going in and watching a
superhero movie way more than was
already standard you you know they're
gonna win and they're gonna be okay
which I mean theoretically sets up
the film's who go in a different
direction to really catch your legs out
from under you except I'm not sure
that's really happened much but um no
III get your point there I think that's
that's a pretty fair thought process
pretty fair criticism I really don't
like the movie bumblebee it feels cliche
and the 80s stuff feels so for us I
still haven't seen bumblebee it's not
high on my list of priorities again cuz
I never got into transformers
I don't like spider-man 2 I have never
liked spider-man 2 ooh
Catherine that is that that's a strong
stance um my feelings on the Raimi
spider-man movies in general is a bit
mixed because like I appreciate what
they're doing but what they're doing a
lot of the time I don't especially
careful but I do really like spider-man
too specifically but hey you know you
just stick to your guns on popular
opinion Pirates of the Caribbean to m3
are great movies yes yes Pirates of the
Caribbean did not get bad into the
fourth one the second and third ones are
the second and third aren't as good but
they're still good they're very
underrated but unfortunately the the
fourth and I I didn't watch the fifth
one but I heard that wasn't much better
that it's really gotten phoned in and
that's tarnished whatever legacy the
original trilogy had which is a shame
transformers is a really fun film well
I've seen the first Transformers film
and I didn't like it and people were
telling me oh well the first one is the
best one I'm like I didn't like that so
I'm definitely not gonna watch the later
ones new who classic who are Big Finish
I think any is a totally valid answer
depending on what your own personal
preferences are for me right now it's
still new whoo I need to dig into enough
classic and Big Finish
I don't think classic is ever going to
overtake new who for me if I absorb
enough
Big Finish maybe we'll see
I also dislike Rose Tyler my mother
couldn't stand Rose Tyler my mother
loves Martha to absolute death and she
couldn't stand Rose so people are saying
the audio is off compete are people
hearing me okay I'm gonna get a second
see what I get for reaction on there
yeah I can I can heat I can hear ya hear
you okay okay okay cool
you don't like Bruce other roses fine
roses middling for me audio gets that
going now and then ah annoying jelly
babies are delicious having had them no
they are not so the Green Lantern is a
good movie oh yeah that's that's a
choice heading back to the discord Star
Wars is incredibly important to me but I
feel that episode 9 is going to be
almost pure damage control for how
fractured the fan base has become I also
believe that Disney's pushing a movie
out when they don't actually have a
story to tell
um I don't I'm not taking that as a
given it's a fear like that would be the
worst way to make episode 9 is to treat
it as damage control because whatever
it's going to be at this point the
people who didn't like episode 8 are
almost definitely not gonna like episode
9 unless it does actually literally
retcon episode 8 and I cannot imagine
Disney actually doing that and I think
it's far more likely that they're gonna
stick to their guns stick to whatever
the plan is for episode 9 and if they're
gonna do something that is primarily a
bid for fan goodwill it's
me with whatever new trilogy of stuff
they do after that I think they need to
stay the course with what they've got
otherwise they're gonna end up with with
a trilogy that's gonna be an even bigger
mess it already is and I already think
it's a little bit of a mess so my
biggest unpopular opinion oh okay this
is the big one folks mmm this is from
the discord I and I'm gonna say the way
it's written
I hate Wesley from The Princess Bride
I'm fine with the rest of the movie but
he makes me want to stab things I can't
explain it it's a visceral thing Wow the
first time I've ever heard that I've
heard people who don't like buttercup
I've heard that I've never heard of
Wesley hate before that ooh now here's
the one thing I have to wonder whether
or not you've seen anything else that
has um oh god I've lost his name all of
a sudden the actor who's suddenly I
can't remember his name I had it a
second ago he's in the new season
stranger things for crying out loud Cary
Elwes thank you oh god I knew is Cary
something thank you pirates so I have to
wonder like do you have that reaction to
him in everything or have you seen him
in things where you liked him and it's
really just something about this
specific performance cuz like I have
actors where like I have that visceral
like I just don't like you Sam Rockwell
I just don't like him so that's my
question as to whether it's you don't
like Wesley or you don't like Cary Elwes
but that's that that was a bold one I
kinda I kind of really like that I'm a
frost in first class and and first class
as a whole makes me want to murder
someone
haha Elizabeth I want to put you in the
room where the podcasting friend of mine
named shag because I he and I the only
reason we didn't come to ver
blows over first class was because the
podcaster that we were recording on that
it came up on he was technically
facilitating it wasn't supposed to be
taking part in the discussion so he
thinks it's like the best thing ever
I don't so
death to the unbeliever oh man
Karen Gillan deserves Awards buzz more
than Robert Downey jr. for endgame its
Downey getting awards buzz that would be
that would be strange to me but my
favorite doctors Peter Cushing I can't I
I saw haven't seen those so Dirk Gently
is superior to the Hitchhiker's Guide
let's put a while since I've reread Dirk
Gently I think they're a little
unfocused for my taste
they yeah I mean they're solid I like
them it's Adams he's good um DC or
marvel which do you prefer I like both
for different reasons but ultimately if
you're going to force me to choose I'm
going to go with Marvel I like their
overall approach a little bit better and
that's broadly speaking that's comics
and movies but when DC is good DC is
excellent but if you're gonna force me
to pick just one I'm gonna go Marvel
rock and roll is dead and has not had
any great true rock band since the 90s
okay Gabe my question to you is what
would you consider to be the last great
rock band I am curious it's okay so this
is this is about Cary Elwes it took me a
long time to warm up to him but I
eventually did but I didn't like him
because of the movie I didn't dislike
the movie because of him okay so it is
something about that character and that
specific performance that turns you out
okay that is
interesting I'm popular opinion Marvel
has better heroes DC as better villian
is that an unpopular opinion cuz I feel
like that's I feel like that's just an
understanding
maybe I'm nuts
do you watch hello future me did a great
rewrite of the Game of Thrones finale
and the Battle of Winterfell no never
heard of them
have you ever seen West Side Story yeah
ages ago ages and ages and ages ago I
don't really remember much besides
tonight
I remember tonight - 9 - 9 8 can't keep
singing this song because I will get
slapped with copyright there you go have
fun um are you looking forward to the
new bat woman series I'm curious about
it um I haven't seen the crossover yet
so I haven't seen the bat this bat woman
at all so um I don't have a like I'm not
that invested yet but I like that woman
as character I like Kate Kane a lot so
I'm curious I think classic who can drag
and be really slow a lot of the time but
I enjoy doing it I actually I I would
agree with that
copyright claimed yeah well hopefully
I'm off key enough that the bots don't
pick it up I'm hoping that that works my
favor
I prefer DC they're much darker
marvelous for kitties
I'll dispute the notion that marvel that
Marvel is for kitties and I would also
actually just be the idea that DC's
darker DC became darker starting in the
80s and I don't actually think that's
been to their benefit I think there are
certain specific characters that work
well doing dark things Batman worked
quite well
going dark with him but they after the
success with Batman and going that route
they
tried to apply it to a lot of other
characters word does not fed that's part
of my issue with DC overall do you like
the 100 have not seen it not a single
episode DC is a kiddie thing but in an
emo phase hahaha
well like part of the thing is I tend to
dispute the general premise that dark
equals more mature because nine times
out of ten dark is kind of like what you
said it's an emo phase it it's very
immature actually it's very sophomoric
it's very superficial like properly
disturbingly dark not just like ooh
Joker took his face off that's not dark
that's just gory you know a little sick
but that's not dark
that's not dark the way stuff that
shakes you to your soul is dark not that
I'm saying DC should even be doing that
but like you want to Watchmen is dark
like legitimately dark a lot of what DC
does is just bleak bleak is not the same
as dark bleak is just depressing and it
often doesn't have a sense of meaning to
it I suppose that's my unpopular DC
opinion because but again the thing is
you can cite me and I'll even agree with
some specific examples where that
approach has worked very well for them
but again the problem I have with DC is
they keep taking that approach and
trying to apply it across the board it
doesn't work for everybody I need to
stop trying to make it do that I'm a big
fan of Gotham scarecrow I think the
actor playing Jonathan crane doesn't get
enough credit well they recast kick or a
couple times on Gotham Peter Capaldi was
by far the worst doctor alright I know
who's trying to be respectful and
everything but I just gotta ban this
comment or write that no I'm not
actually gonna do that but like
now I've offended DC fans I can finally
sleep haha
Batman isn't as compelling without Robin
I don't know about Robin specifically
but Batman does need to have his
relationships with other people
otherwise he's a boring loner so whether
that focus be Alfred whether it be back
or whether it be Robin whether it be
whoever whether it be Callan whether it
be Selina like he needs his other
relationships otherwise yeah he's very
boring
have you watched Stargate I've seen the
film I never watched the show DC and
Marvel are both terrible well yeah
that's an opinion okay everybody take a
drink cuz I just got the question
Sandman on Netflix thoughts there's an
entire video it just went up last week
everybody take a drink I'm popular
pinging cartoons can be for adults and
teenagers without being called anime yes
yeah my favorite um mature animations
that aren't anime is stuff that the
reason it's not for kids is because it's
too challenging for kids and it's it's
requiring too much or too it's like it's
too heavy for kids and would never
appeal to them so like the max animated
series that's not for kids I consider
that to be pretty mature and it's
bizarre and ethereal and strange or
waking life quick show of hands anybody
even know what I'm talking about when I
say waking life but like that's not for
kids but it's also got no swearing no
violence no nudity but like it's dealing
with all these big heavy philosophical
continent concepts and not for kids and
that that's the kind of maturity that I
love especially what I can find that it
animated form and yeah it is unfortunate
that you don't get that in Western
animation and usually you have to kind
of go to anime to get any exploration of
that kind of stuff but like Netflix's
animation approach to stuff like
Castlevania and Ken and Buster's calling
it Netflix original anime uh well I mean
the thing about Castlevania those
Castlevania is visually aesthetically
anime I don't know the other one that
you mentioned but like if you want to
take issue with calling something anime
because at least so far as I know it's
not originating in Japan although the
animation studio might be out of Japan I
don't know but like it's being
originally written for an English
language and it's not starting out in
Japanese if you want to UM say that
that's not proper anime that's one thing
but certainly visually stylized
Castlevania the Netflix series which I
love is very anime much like the games
Castlevania are very animate visually
hey there Claudia
oh hey heavenly imaginings good to see
you I I got it I got to get better at um
[Music]
it's sort of greeting the regulars I
guess Ichi the Killer anime is too
mature for kids Ichi the Killer anime is
too mature for adults yeah
uh as amazing as restaurant at the end
of the universe was overall it really
slugs for about two chapters in the
middle which two chapters I'm curious do
you like Scanner Darkly
I haven't seen it in a long time I need
to watch it again I remember wishing I
liked it more than I did um but you know
it's it's it's been a long time since
I've seen it the doctor shooting someone
made me so angry oh yeah that's that's
on the pile of sins of hell-bent for
they are Allegiant wolf children easily
my favorite anime just grabbed me in the
right way
my daughter loves wolf children and I
love it too but the thing is like that
like well children is a great film to
share with your kids if you think they'd
enjoy it because kids and adults will
appreciate that story on completely
different levels it's really good
did you talk about the Little Mermaid I
missed it
do you mean like in this chat like not
not other than good shrugging and going
I don't know what's wrong with people
doesn't like that's kind of the extent
to which I talk about it um do you think
socializing with Max will give 11 false
ideas of what other teenage girls are
like I mean no more than how screwed up
her perceptions of everything kind of
already are I can't imagine it's gonna
cause any more damage than everything
else she's gonna she's already been
through here we are lying dead standing
standing dead in this desolate
restaurant ah I love that book so much
scarecrow is one of those villains that
has creeped me out in almost every
version I've seen I've really liked some
of the redesigns on scarecrow over the
years actually you know was the one that
was really creepy I think it was the the
third season of Batman the Animated
Series cuz they did a redesign on a lot
of the characters and some of them did
not look good like the read isn't
Catwoman look like garbage but the
redesigned Scarecrow they like he had
this very hollow look in the eyes in the
mouth and he had a noose around his neck
like a necktie Oh was so more of it it
was great
let's see I'm gonna hop on back to the
discord I gotta catch up on a few of
these here contrarian opinion most of my
guilty pleasures aren't what people
would expect great a weirdness like
Barbarella Zardoz phantom of the
paradise Howard the Duck Forbidden Zone
the only one of those that I've seen is
um I receive any part of his Zardoz I
saw the first I don't know five minutes
of Zardoz it went nope I just great that
I was also like 22 I was really young
but like I just I just couldn't with
that movies I'm less likely to advertise
my affection for stuff on the wholesome
end and scale like Pollyanna Godspell on
The Parent Trap original version yeah
like I feel like sometimes it's like
considered cheesy to express your love
of stuff that is just sweet like we we
grow up we're supposed to be deep and
dark and think dark things and have
melancholy experiences and really get
into the depths of the darkness of human
nature it's like sometimes you just want
to you just want to pop and lassi and I
think we get embarrassed to say
something like that but no that's valid
that's totally valid Steven Moffat early
2005 to 2009 episodes are boring
ha ok so you're talking you're talking
the empty child girl in the fireplace I
mean if you're not hooked into the
relationship maybe I could see that one
is boring blink it's deliberately paced
boring seems like a stretch signs in the
library force of the dead I mean that
kind of takes off like a rocket if I'm
honest but ok
I love those movies I'm all for
lightness and happiness never
embarrassed about it that's good to hear
screw that I'm an adult night like
cheesy corny stuff haha uh I thought
they were boring no I get it cool and
like when I when I'm like I don't see it
That's not me trying to invalidate your
opinion your opinions your opinion
actually I'm interested dear because now
I'm like I'm trying to think back on
those episodes ago okay but like for me
they totally worked but much like I'm
not gonna say somebody's wrong cuz they
like something that I didn't I'm gonna
not gonna say the year wrong for finally
something boring that I really enjoy no
it's fine
just hard to get my head into that space
at all I love Judge Dredd 1995 oh I
don't know if I love it but it's pretty
fun
Trane's I love this there's a guy's like
just the word with a question mark
I don't know Wendelin what do you think
thank you best guess 2001 a Space
Odyssey is what I call bori hi the
middle third of that movie I think is
pretty dang good the opening the ending
don't care I don't don't care for that
movie I like I've mentioned this before
not a big Kubrick fan really only two of
his movies that I like and one of them
do I think the only reason that I like
it is because I was at the exact right
age to see it that was a Clockwork
Orange saw when I was in college was
just kind of like the perfect age to see
that movie if I'd seen it when I was
much older I would have been like I
don't know about this so like that and
dr. Strangelove and honestly probably
the same thing I saw that when I was in
college too so I think those just caught
me at the right time but other than that
[Laughter]
okay I'm gonna try very hard not to be a
jerk about this but so the follow-up
question to trans question mark was do
you have a penis or a vagina I'm gonna
assume that's a typo or they're being
cute um here's the thing if you're
curious as to whether or not someone is
trans that is absolutely not the way to
ask that question ever ever
you don't ask another human being about
the generals
cuz it's none of your business like how
would you feel if somebody who you
didn't know said hey full bush are
shaved you'd be offended
and to ask that question I'm gonna right
now I'm extending the benefit of the
doubt that you're not trolling me but
that's about the rudest possible way
that you could ask that question because
the answer is very simply absolutely
none your business and does and to pull
a line from my own sets that I've used
on stage before unless you plan to meet
me alone in in a hotel room at a later
date it's absolutely none of your
business what I've got going on and even
if that was the case within 30 seconds
you wouldn't care anyway
so let's see got a pop on back so back
in the discord
I love the 13th doctor she's my second
favorite who I was it has absolutely
nothing to do with the fact that she's a
woman she kept a quirkiness of the
doctor which is the main reason I love
the doctor so much but the biggest thing
is that her sense of wonder and
hopefulness has returned she's she's
just a more positive upbeat doctor than
we've had in a very long time I'm
disappointed that she can get more
character development this season fair I
haven't gotten to know her very well but
I like what I've seen so far this does
not however mean I love series 11 after
a while after several watches it doesn't
seem as bad as it did it first
when expectations were high but it still
has problems it's not my favorite season
but at least it's doctor who hopefully
lessons will be learned for series 12
well you I are definitely on the same
page first series 11 overall and yeah
like the the thirteenth doctor I I feel
like I only just like got her at the
very end of of that of series 11 but
that being said um you know I I can't
appreciate that all of the doctors we've
had since knew who started have been
very angsty very troubled and yeah if
you want just a doctor who goes and has
adventures
Whitakers doctor seems primed to do that
as opposed to just being mated down with
the burden of everything now that's I've
actually enjoyed that but like we had
that for four doctors in a row so yeah
you know what there's a validity to kind
of dropping that and going a bit lighter
let's see here
sorry hang on empty child and doctor
dances are great I just think I just
think fire so girl in the fireplace
blink and library were
but that's only my opinion must be my
own braid also also eff transphobia
thank you for that
umm yeah now I sometimes like here's the
thing I get the thing where you're like
maybe that's just my brain cuz I feel
like that's me sometimes especially like
when I try and explain my thought
processes on my takeaways from things
like trailers people are always like why
can't you be positive why can't you just
get excited I'm like that's not how my
brain works I wish I could I wish I
could do something other than zero in on
what I think the most likely problems
and the potholes and you know the big
traps that the that the things gonna
have to avoid that he just saw the
trailer for but that's just the way my
brain works so I get like just the whole
thing of it that's just not how I
process so it doesn't work for me I'm
actually totally on board with you on
that I'm a critic at heart aren't we all
angles disappointed rant was Jed was
generally terrify I would hate to get
out of his bad side but in all
seriousness it was an insensitive
question I I I try to you know to keep
my sense of decorum as best I can but
yeah I I've inadvertently frightened
people what my switch got flipped not
like I've cause like I've never liked
lash I'm not a physically yeah person
I've never been in a fight but like I've
had people tell me like okay something
just happened where like you got this
look and I'm like I'm kind of nervous
ound like yeah it's cuz I'm kind of
ticked have you played any of the dark
room video games as yet I have not so
let me get back to this card got a few
more of these I gotta get through I
didn't hate fantastic beasts - well I'm
happy for you I wish I hadn't uh only
because you asked for controversial
takes I don't want to start a fight I
believe that the oh okay
I believe I believe that at best the
Bush administration knew about 9/11
prior and chose to do nothing have worst
it was an inside job or cruise
orchestrated by the PNAC uh you'll
forgive me for not touching that one I
did promise I would I would bring them
all up in the chat I'm just yeah yeah
I'm gone I'm leaving that one alone
hopefully you'll forgive me for that but
you know what props when I that's a
controversial opinion you did not you
did not mess around here sorry I'm gonna
do one more off the
core because I haven't been doing them
quite at the pace that I meant to and
I'm oh Jesus more of them came in uh uh
I'm a fan of wrestling and if we talk
Attitude Era
I hate Stone Cold Steve Austin which is
weird because I love the man persona of
Becky Lynch based on Austin I hate the
rock love Dwayne Johnson though but I
really like the Undertaker and love
Triple H 2 bits he is tied for my
favorite wrestler with thin Bale or I
don't know a lot of these names oh and I
liked John Cena before Oh God
thug out thug anomic s-- but hated him
after he started doing that just get
myself some more water I love Kurt Angle
the whole time I'm a huge Hardy Boys fan
but is my favorite and I think Jeff is
totally overrated and kind of boring
without his brother I always like
Christian better than edge I thought
right to censor was hilarious and
awesome
for anything more related to the channel
I enjoyed the daredevil in Electra
movies okay that what I can actually
respond to the badass like daredevil
movie is I don't under rated feels like
a stretch over haded is what I would
call the Ben Affleck daredevil movie
there's actually quite a bit that's
quite good in that including hats like
himself I think he's actually genuinely
good in the part
as for the Elektra movie I'm I'm one of
like five people that actually saw that
in the theater and I didn't hate it it
wasn't good though it like I just didn't
know what they wanted it to be like at
all it was just kind of there water sure
water it is my water mug
hydrating
as you have said you're a big fan of
Simon Pegg and Nick Frost would you
consider doing a bit video on the free
three flavours Cornetto trilogy um only
if I think I could add something that
hasn't already been said about it that's
always kind of the trick with something
like that because like I feel like sine
Edgar Wright's work in general is the
kind of stuff that gets really
thoroughly picked over with a fine-tooth
comb
by people like me and has already been
done by people who are probably better
at this than I am
so like maybe like maybe I cuz I forget
what he's working on now
maybe in the lead up to Edgar Wright's
next film
maybe I'll revisit those three and like
do a combined thing I probably wouldn't
do a full review for each one hi trading
intensifies I count the 1996 Doctor Who
movie is a New Year special actually you
could yeah it didn't air near New Year's
though it just was set during it
it was a huge missed opportunity to not
make Hawkeye def in the MCU I just
wonder if they did if they weren't sure
that they would be able to sell it but
like it would have been cool
I think Martha's a bad companion mhm
well you're wrong but no no like it's an
opinion I don't agree with that one but
I'm enjoying dehydrating right now sis
sips whiskey and coke
keep in mind I do not just like Steven
Moffat and also thought his series
finales were complete let downs like the
build-up didn't match the actual finale
actually I'd agree with that
more often than not this will come up as
I eventually get to his stuff with
overdue Doctor Who but more often than
not he had killer penultimate episodes
to his series and then like not
especially good finales more often than
not on popular opinion I never found the
show jackass 2 to be very funny well I
never got into us I couldn't really say
one way or another it's just not really
my style of humor they didn't like
Starfire on Titans I'm still trying to
figure out how did Starfire become a
prostitute um I mean I kind of a she was
like masquerading as one possibly belly
that's a little harsh
I'm popular opinion I don't think the
show Jack has the funny yeah I saw that
one all right I um I will say this like
I was in a bad mood and I did on a whim
see jackass 3d in the theater and I did
actually have a good time with that it
did pep up my mood it didn't make me
want to see anything else they done but
I wasn't sorry that I saw that Adam West
was the best Batman he is he is a unique
Batman certainly he's actually quite
good I I do like Adam West a lot
what do you mean Starfire is a
prostitute okay if you've seen the new
Titans series
Starfire we still don't know the full
deal with her cuz like she's only just
been getting her memory back but she
appeared to have been infiltrating what
some underground things posing as as an
escort of some fashion and that's sort
of accounts for her look in the series
ah I don't even like Batman is that an
unpopular pain yes haha yes it is
have you got a favorite black and white
old movie ooh
it's either gonna be the Maltese Falcon
or after The Thin Man because there's my
unpopular opinion well first of all hey
you have to be in tall movies even know
the Thin Man series which is great they
keep rumored that they're gonna remake
it they should not it's awesome
but the Thin Man is a is a comedy
mystery series and generally everyone
says the first one the best they
disagree I think the second one's the
best so there's there's an unpopular
opinion there I remember you kind of
scare me when you mentioned when I
mentioned I would like the fashioner
odds or return and you read it hahaha it
was my first time on this dream oh well
I'm glad you came back slicks I'm real
I'm sorry I'm glad I didn't totally
scare you off then man remade totally
need to leave that series alone oh I
know like I haven't heard that for a
while like I remember about a decade
hearing that like oh well good Johnny
Depp teacher I was like no that was even
before I had full Johnny Depp burn out
and I'm still like no I don't think they
were talking about that anymore though
thankfully it's a small world is not an
annoying song oh it's like that
quintessential oh man
popular opinion Steve Rogers is a bad
character and a bad hero yes III would
say that is that is an unpopular opinion
um let's see I found Matt Smith's doctor
I'm going back to the discord here I
found Matt Smith's doctor and Amy Pond
incredibly boring until Rory joined in
Haiti Capaldi start well I like hating
Capaldi start I kinda simple
with insofar as I liked him better every
series he was in I didn't hate him at
the start but I didn't like I didn't
start loving him until down the line
[Music]
let's see
scroll down here sorry I'm still going
through the discord it looked like it
like a little chat started going back
and forth so I have to sort out what
people were just talking between
themselves to and you know the actual
things that wanted to be shared here is
this topic like the argument sketch in
Monty Python no it isn't yes it is okay
okay so we're gonna venture slightly off
degree here again from the discord I
know one contrarian opinion some have
but I think it is so wrong that you that
you cannot be Christian and believe that
people who are LGBTQ our centers simply
for the fact that they live that
lifestyle first it says that we should
love all also people that are in love no
matter or what no matter how that is
expressed is doing what is right the
funny thing is that Christians feel that
sex without being married is sinful but
if they don't want LGBTQ people to marry
them what can they do
also as Groucho Marx put it whatever it
is I'm against it what's always been
very curious to me and and like I don't
want to delve into this too much cuz I
myself am NOT Christian I wasn't raised
Christian so like I'm speaking from an
outsider's perspective on this that so
like I am NOT I wish I was on sounder
footing knowledge wise but the religion
to the extent that I understand it
what's very strange to me when
Christians condemn
things like homosexuality and actually
added quite a number of things but
that's kind of the big one that's pulled
from a book in the Old Testament where
as Christ's actual teachings are all in
the New Testament those teachings being
primarily love each other so it's very
strange to me because like in my mind
and again outside of looking in what it
feels like it should be is that the
teachings of the New Testament are meant
to if not completely supersede the Old
Testament to be then be the new
authority voice of authority like this
was the old way of thinking here is the
new way of thinking here is your new
gospel and so it's very strange to me
when Christians who theoretically are
primarily following the teachings of
Christ in the New Testament cite the Old
Testament for their condemnation of some
things that it's very strange to me for
that reason alone before I even get into
anything else that's always one of those
things that I that I found very
confusing because like the the Bibles is
incredibly you know self contradictory
so there's a lot of picking and choosing
going on
I'm trams MTF but raised Catholic and I
still am and you know what that I
actually I have a lot more than I would
have thought friends who are some degree
of trans who are who still actively
engage in their faith I think there's a
narrative out there that if you are
religious and trans being trans involves
breaking away from your religion and I
haven't found that to be true I have a
couple of friends who like go to church
every Sunday I have a non-binary friend
to church every single Sunday I have a
trans man friend
ghost church every Sunday his wife is
involved with the church and you know
he's he's still working through the you
know sort of the big sort of parts of
his transition so he's still fairly
early into it so it's not even like
ancient history for him yet and it's um
it's just it's funny to me that that
there is this sort of belief that faith
and being trans or gay or whatever are
incompatible and that's not been my
experience even speaking of someone who
does not engage in formalized faith but
just through people I know I know that's
not true we actually have some LGBTQ
people in my church and I've had a
conversation with someone about LGBTQ
and how it has now how we can be seen as
linked to a relationship with God
oh okay man how Christians systems work
is both see the rules are set in the
days of old and the new way of thinking
aka and your new testament still keep
some of the old rules okay I get that
but it I mean again I don't know it just
feels like okay forgive me for being
crass and I'm not trying to crab on my
knees but tonally just talking in terms
of tone and the vibe of the books
because I have not cover to cover but I
have read portions of the Bible Old
Testament and knew I had to for various
classes at various points so like just
the vibe I get Old Testament feels like
it was written by an angry drunk and New
Testament feels like it was written by
the same person after being sober for
two years
so like I get that it's all coming from
the same person but I like I feel like
this perspective is kind of expected to
take precedent over this one and that
was probably a really crass way of
putting it I probably got a ultimately
regret saying it that way but I'm just
talking in terms of tone and vibe I'm
not trying to call God a drug huh nor am
i implying that I am God as I sit my
water
you could also been mistranslated well
that's actually okay boy we've really
gotten into the weeds on this um the the
question of mistranslation is actually
one of the driving reasons as to why I
have always been reluctant to engaged in
in formalized faith because unless you
know fluently the language that the
Bible was originally or any religious
text was originally written in then and
this and this is primarily an impact on
on Christianity but would be a impact on
me with anything cuz anything I you know
I wouldn't know that language but it's
something that like the Jewish faith
kind of has the advantage on because
they've kept Hebrew lives the language
but anyway the point that I was getting
to you know when people quote the Bible
you know chapter and verse at me they're
quoting English which means they're
quoting a translation the leap of faith
involved to assume that nowhere along
the line did the translators to say
nothing of the people who initially put
pen to paper did not in some way
misinterpret twist or rework the message
to their advantage or to their intrinsic
believed that's a leap of faith I can't
make because people you know
ooh I don't know if that goof is
directed at me how many people have I
lost out of the chat on this whole
tangent I've gone on oh boy I feel like
religion is the old form of therapy from
way back when that's an interesting
perspective when people say read the
Bible my question back is which one
that's a valid response video it's funny
I'm always incredibly self-conscious
about touching on subjects like religion
because I know it's something that
people have really deep-seated feelings
about and it can be a very fraught topic
but the thing is broadly speaking I
actually love talking about it the same
reason I like talking about things like
say philosophy I love the concepts and I
love trying to wrap my head around it
partly knowing that I'm not gonna be
able to fully wrap my head around it
though like that the basis of Maya okay
I can't help but find it funny that that
kicked out as I started to go on a on a
religion spirituality rant or whatever
to take that as a sign you just quit
while I'm ahead
I think I'm just gonna go ahead and do
that okay
and we worried you didn't actually mr.
renkins as soon as I started started
buffering cuz they actually have it on
my into I stopped talking
so nobody is sending we're gonna break
the record for longest council of geeks
livestream Oh possibly how late oh jeez
this is going well okay let me go back
to the discord see if there anymore that
I missed
I love the Ewoks movie actually the
first one's kind of fun second one's not
good I love you walks and pours Fugees a
lot a lot of love for the Oh huh
somebody that this Court did still
clarify but not Jar Jar Binks okay so
there are still limits they're still
aligned cool oh oh okay this is from the
discord this feels like a personal
attack pickles taste horrible but at
least they're not as bad as Tomatoes
okay
tomatoes I will grant are not for
everybody
Liz doesn't like tomatoes fine
but pickles I burn through a pickle jar
I burned through pickles at a rate of
two jars a wink and I'm usually not even
here for two or three days out of the
week because I'm off seeing Liz and
whenever I go see Liz she makes sure to
stock up on two things pickles and salsa
I guess what's the primary basis salsa
Tomatoes yeah I eat I eat a lot of
pickles pickles are my go-to like I'm
kind of hungry but I don't know what I
want I'll have a pickle or actually more
accurately I will have four pickles so
yeah all right and that's dill by the
way like bread and butter sweet but
those are not pickles
there's something else if it's not dill
it's not a pickle
all right that you can still add extra
things to it you can do spicy you can do
garlic but if it's not Dill's not a
pickle
I and I will not entertain anything to
the contrary I think I'm I think I've
almost got all the discord stuff Oh
dolly parton's i will always love you is
better than Whitney Houston's rendition
well she certainly got the benefit of
being the original Daleks and Manhattan
evolution Daleks were also very
enjoyable
[Music]
I love Jupiter ascending I've heard that
I still have seen Jupiter ascending
though how bands actually great not
perfect but I love it whoo boy ya know
I'm not gonna go down that road but
Titus is absolutely the best film
covering any Shakespeare's work also
screw Romeo and Juliet in general two
things there first is yes Titus is great
it is a wonderful interpretation of
Shakespeare I'm not sure it's my
favorite I'm also very partial to
Richard the third the one with Ian
McKellen but Titus is very good
additionally though Romeo and Juliet I'm
not gonna say to hell with the Romeo and
Juliet I am gonna say to hell with
anyone who says Romeo and Juliet is
romantic because it's not it's not
romantic it is a tragedy and Romeo and
Juliet are idiots that's not a plot hole
that's the point of the story it is to
hormonal teenagers who just friggin met
ruining their lives and the lives of
their family because they're horny
that's the point of the story
it is not romantic and anyone who says
it is was it paying attention the
Scottish play is my favorite Shakespeare
play yes I'm a theatre person so I'm
paranoid and I'm gonna say it that way
more deep relationships are bad I should
know I think most of us can vouch for
that from some stupid decision somewhere
ah though the play is actually pretty
dirty people don't expect that Oh
Shakespeare's filthy it's um my
daughter's mother teaches theater in
high school and the quickest way she can
get high schoolers to be interested in
Shakespeare is to quote them a line of
Shakespeare and explain that it's it's a
dick joke cuz there's a lot of them
that okay I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
read anything any of these out loud but
the some interesting conversations going
on right now do you know the real reason
for the Scottish play curse I know the
superstition among theater people do I
know the real reason possibly probably
not
[Music]
I like ham cool Drake tell exams was not
fun
oh we buffering are we back
ah hey buffering buffering is it
buffering for everybody really bad
buffering there sing back hang on gonna
check something here give me a second
back back yes back for me
okay okay I okay I think I think we've
got it now okay
sorry about that for me it's still
buffering ah sorry dude okay anyways ah
I love the red nose special with Tennant
and Catherine Tate where she quotes one
of the one Shakespeare sonnet at him
like I first of all like one of the big
mistakes we make in trying to teach the
aged hears about Shakespeare is we make
them read it
Shakespeare is not meant to be read
Shakespeare's meant to be seen it is
meant to be your embodied by an actor
that is like reading a play I'm not
saying it has no value but that is not
the way in which it is meant to be taken
in that's like trying to teach somebody
about Kubrick by having them read the
script to 2001 like you're doing a
disservice to what you're trying to
teach so it's very strange to me that
Shakespeare such a staple of English
classes I'm assuming in the UK too but
you know from my experience in the US
but you know the focus is on just read
the play and maybe if you're lucky your
school will take you like to one trip to
see to see it get performed and I think
that's a big part of why I think
lot of people kind of don't appreciate
Shakespeare because until you like
especially the language the language is
not nearly as tough to get through if
you're seeing it performed if you're
getting the context of seeing characters
react and how they say it in the
inflection and their voice you don't
need to get the words in order to get
the meaning
well this stream is long yeah it's gone
on a while I think I am gonna oh god
I've gone about an hour and a half I
think it's time to call it a night
this one's been all over the place this
one this this was fun it really did run
the gamut and and go everywhere I'm
popular opinion last Jetta is the best
Star Wars I'm ready to get mugged as
soon as I step outside
watch your back Andrew I'm not saying
I'm gonna be the one mugging you I'm
just saying I might be video recording
whoever does
catch you later thanks for talking
thanks a lot this one went long but I
had fun so thanks a lot and until next
time everybody you are beautiful you are
loved you are valid you're the council
and thank you for joining me for this
particular meeting of it so till next
time everybody